Jason Statham has become a modern-day
Action Man punching and kicking his way
through film after film however it looks
like his latest role will pit the
cockney Hardman not against humans but a
giant prehistoric shock
I'm Simon and this is your fish fighting
news update expendable star Jason
Statham has faced a wide variety of
enemies in his career but the actor will
soon take on his biggest scariest
adversary to date it has been reported
that Statham has signed on to top-line
the long in development giant shock
thriller make according to The Hollywood
Reporter Statham will star in the
monster movie which is to be directed by
Jon Turteltaub best known for the
national treasure films the film is
based on the 1997 novel make a novel of
deep terror written by Steve Alton
development on a film adaptation of make
began in 1997 and is moved between
Studios ever since with directors such
as Jan de Bont and Guillermo del Toro
attached at various stages the film will
be a co-production between Warner and
Chinese company gravity and reportedly
the location of the story will now
change from the Mariana Islands near the
Philippines to the coast of China will
you go deep blue sea this movie think
it'll be awesome let me know in the
comments below or find me on Twitter I'm
at the Jagan all thanks for watching
have all your entertainment news keep it
GameSpot
you